which brings us to the other side the
other camp
and Republicans who in an effort to own
the libs
which seems to be their only function
they are pushing back against every
measure imaginable
to beat back the virus whether that be
mask mandates whether that be vaccines
whether that be social distancing
whether that be shutdowns uh whatever
effect they had on the economy
at every step
they push back
enter
Josh feuerstein
another one of these Evangelical Nutter
Butters who screams and yells and freaks
out on stage to Their audience
their congregation
listen again get a little personal since
most people don't know who I am
I grew up a Conservative Republican
I was indoctrinated in an Evangelical
congregation for most of my child for
all of my childhood
I revered characters like Josh
feuerstein like Greg Locke
Who David talked about a few days ago
these are dangerous charlatans watch
this clip from Josh feuerstein then
we're going to talk about it listen to
me I understand and let me speak now to
the cameras around the world to every
Pastor that's watching this broadcast to
every Christian that is powered in your
home I realize that for this last year
that maybe you've been fed fear and fear
and fear but the Bible says that God has
not given us the spirit of fear but a
power and of love and a sound mind you
have a sound mind you don't have to wear
the mask you got Jesus you don't need
the vaccine you got Jesus
[Music]
so I guess we're to believe that Josh
feuerstein who much like me could could
use a few sit-ups in his life
that he's not vaccinated for anything
apparently he doesn't have the the
measles mumps rubella vaccine
he's probably not been vaccinated for
polio right
it's only this vaccine that's the
problem because it's the culture War du
jour for conservatives
and grifters
just like him
who ostensibly has a charge to protect
his flock
he is doing a disservice not just to the
people in that audience who look up to
him and admire him he is doing a
disservice to the country at Large
as he appears on America real America's
voice
like they're part of real America and
those of us who disagree
are not in real America
this is all part and parcel pattern and
practice with uh what is taking place
right now in the headlines uh faren
talked about over the last couple days a
couple of guys
um
dick Farrell the Newsmax and Florida
radio host who who said not to get
vaccinated who called covet a hoax who's
now dead
from covid
H Scott aptly a Republican
the leader in the Republican party in
Texas
average a mass burning party
and said boy I wish I could live where
you guys are I'd love to be a part of
that
he died on Wednesday
in an effort to own the libs
to prove their points
they're acting as they always do about
most issues of import
and that is until it passes beyond their
nose
like a like a conservative who is all
against gay rights until they have a gay
kid
the same thing is happening because the
two gentlemen that I just talked about
that have been talked about more in
length by farron the last few days
their their families are admonishing
everyone please get the vaccine covet is
real covet is a killer
and the problem that we face right now
is not just from local city councilmen
in Texas or Newsmax radio hosts
it's with
prominent governors in the Republican
party like Ron DeSantis right now
who just today announced he's
threatening to cut the pay suspend the
pay of of school districts of teachers
Educators
superintendents if they enforce a mask
mandate protecting children this
headline from cbs4 Miami Governor Ron
DeSantis office State education board
could withhold salaries of
superintendents school board members who
Implement Mass mandates here's the the
word from Ron DeSantis
someone who is not protecting children
as we see covid rates rise among
children
hospitalization rise among children Ron
DeSantis is making it a policy objective
to not protect the least Among Us the
most vulnerable Among Us
his statement
with respect to enforcing any Financial
consequences for non-compliance of state
law regarding these rules and ultimately
the rights of parents to make decisions
about their children's education and
Health Care decisions it would be the
goal of the State Board of Education to
narrowly tailor any Financial
consequences to the offense committed
for example the State Board of Education
could move to withhold the salary of
this district superintendent or school
board members as a narrowly tailored
means to address the decision makers who
led to the violation of the law
who led to the violation of the law but
also led to the protection of children
he continues education funding is
intended to benefit students first and
foremost
wrong DeSantis said it with his own
mouth here by his own pin or someone in
his office that education fundies
intended to benefit students first and
foremost
and that doesn't just mean
benefiting them and their edu their
actual education but keeping them safe
in the place where they are educated
just recently on Meet the Press with
Chuck Todd the the president of the
second
largest teachers union uh decided
they're going to reverse course and
they're going to support a covid vaccine
mandate because of that very thing
protecting children
uh Randy Weingarten the president of the
American Federation of teachers on with
Meet the Press watch this
um but I do think that the circumstances
have changed and that vaccination is a
community responsibility and it weighs
really heavily on me that kids under 12
can't get vaccinated and so that's so
you know that's I I very rarely you know
separate my personal views from you know
where I am as a leader of the Union but
I have really watched particularly in
Florida and Missouri I was in St Louis
yesterday I was in Florida on Saturday
and and you just see this and and we
have to counter look you said it earlier
we have to counter the misinformation we
have to do we this is a public health
crisis and and the politics are
infecting it but I I felt the need as
you know to bring people together and to
stand up and say this as a matter of
personal conscience pointedly stated
circumstances have changed and this is
about it weighs really heavily on me
that kids under 12 can't get vaccinated
it should weigh heavily on every single
person in America educator or not Pastor
or not politician or not
stupid commentator or not
people are dying our neighbors are dying
In Our Lifetime
unless you're 100 years old
we've not seen something rip through
our society like this
which team are you going to be on
the team that cares
or the team that colludes
against the team that cares
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely free
service at privacy.com Pacman I've been
using privacy for a little over a year
now you've heard me talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone instead of actually using your
real credit card number the privacy app
and the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even auto fill the card number
with one click and the payment is taken
out of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them anytime you want so when you
do this it means you're not going to be
charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free and like I said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign up
at privacy.com Pacman